All right. Hello everyone. So, we are
here. It's June 12th, 2026. We're in the
fourth We're doing the fourth chapter of
Fundamentals of Active Inference by
Sanjeev Namjoshi.
This is the second session of the two
sessions on each chapter. So, we've
already done the first half of chapter
four. Now, we're doing the the sort of
latter half where we're talking about
variational inference. This is the
really cool heart of, you know, the
mathematical machinery of active
inference.
We're seeing the first sort of taste of
that with this chapter. So, I'll start
sharing my screen.
And we'll get ourselves oriented here.
So, share.
Come back over here.
I'm going to try and minimize this.
Maybe I'll just take that.
Okay, LaTeX. Let's go to the actual
page.
So, again, we're in chapter four. We did
um
>> [clears throat]
>> we did sections 4.1 to 4.6 kind of
mostly to the end of 4.3 last time.
Although, there's one example from 4.3
which I would like to go over, the last
example, before we move on.
Um from there, really, the discussion
the the introduction of new concepts is
really kept to a minimum and we sort of
branch out and get a feel for the
different kind of forms of free energy
that crop up in the literature,
basically. And Sanjeev has uh
his unique way of kind of classifying
these different forms of the the the
free energy.
Um and that's kind of what we're going
to take a look at. There's there's
interesting lots of very interesting
connections and analogies to be had
between the different formalisms and
other areas of science like machine
learning.
Um so, that's that's what we're going to
take a look at today.
I must admit I I I
I'm under the pump with a few deadlines.
So, I haven't actually prepared the
the the the rest of the context is here.
But, the kind of map for the chapter, I
haven't done sections 4.3 to 4.6 just
yet. They will they they will be
forthcoming as well. In addition to a
few more kind of animations and things,
uh trying to give a bit more context
about stuff. I will point out as well, I
think Andrew, you have joined but
there's Andrew's very helpful um slides.
They're down here on uh I think it's
next to the code, is that right?
>> Uh no, you you'll find them uh on the
figures.
>> Figures.
>> Page yeah, just below everything.
Um yeah.
>> So these are great. I've been checking
these out. They are they are awesome.
Um
>> Thanks.
>> Very nice difference to to what we've
been going over. What about what where
are the ones for uh chapter four? Are
they all in this uh one here?
>> Yeah, they're they're at the very end
and um they're generally
uh you know, I'm just adding them as we
go. Um there are two of them for chapter
four right now. One of them is almost
entirely dedicated to um Jensen's
inequality.
Uh just because I think that the Yeah,
the way it's presented in the textbook
is a little
um
you know, it's it it it can look a
little confusing because there's a
difference and um
when we apply Jensen's inequality, it's
like there's a difference whenever the
function uh that we're using here is
concave versus convex. And so actually
everything looks a little bit a little
bit backwards if you only look at the
original inequality formula. Um and then
uh it makes some references there to the
2022 textbook as well just to try and
fill in some gaps.
Uh and then the slide uh immediately
prior to that is really just about how
do we say what a good versus bad model
is. Um and looking at surprisal and um
figure 4.7 is like ideally in the kinds
of models that we're building, we should
be able to sort of invert our model to
see how well it predicts the
observations that it will receive, which
is sort of the the opposite direction of
how [snorts] we're usually thinking
about these
models. Um yeah, and that's always been
appealing to me with with these kinds of
models and active inference, the idea of
being able to invert the model, switch
it around, and see what it comes up
with, and
that gets into
model fitting and and all these other
sorts of things that come up in
empirical work. So, um but yeah, uh I'm
happy to add if going forward anyone who
is particularly interested in any topic,
like I'm thinking about adding a slide
regarding all the individual forms of
the variational free energy we get in
chapter four, it might be nice to sort
of have uh a more focused account of
each of those and and why do we have
them? Why is there a C form that has
complexity and a D form with divergence
and so on? So,
um yeah, hope they're helpful to anyone
who's still kind of scratching their
head occasionally with some of these
things.
>> [gasps]
>> Yeah, people, that is that is very
handy. So, the last two slides currently
are on chapter four and they give a bit
more exposition. The So, you're very
right. I think we will we'll try and
maybe go over Jensen's inequality very
uh well, you know, not quickly, but cuz
it is it is a very useful way to think
about the connection that the VFE has to
model evidence. And this is a very
famous figure, well, famous within the
active inference community from the
first textbook, uh the Parr et al.
textbook from 2022.
If I'm not mistaken, there actually
isn't a figure in Sanjeev's textbook on
um
Jensen's inequality, but um anyway,
we're getting ahead of ourselves a
little bit there.
Um
I think we'll we'll get to that. So, do
check out um
Andrew's notes. If you scroll back up
here.
>> Yes.
I'll briefly say that on Tuesday Daniel
actually used um
one of your
um
illustrations that uh the the the
what is it the three blue one brown or
that that
which was very helpful because then we
could actually see Jensen's inequality
like individual eyes like
sort of animated form and you can see
how it it sort of plays out and so that
that's also helpful yeah.
>> I'll be making more of those as we go
along I haven't had time to polish the
current ones and and make more but they
will be something that will feature I
think alongside.
So let's let's get ourselves oriented
with respect to where we left off
we left off effectively kind of at the
very end of section 4.3
and we were looking at this example here
so where are we?
We were looking at
the relationship of hopefully this is
big enough surprise
to model evidence basically so
we know that the big kind of bugbear and
the whole point of this chapter as I
said like in the first session and what
Daniel reiterated the whole point of
this chapter is that we usually cannot
do exact Bayesian inference we do not
have the ability to
compute the exact posterior so we need
to approximate the the exact posterior.
And the bugbear when it comes to
computing the posterior is the
evaluation of this thing called the
model evidence right so the probability
of an observation coming in at all given
any state of the world. This is usually
the thing that's impossible to evaluate
directly so
you know obviously this is within the
notation of the the textbook currently
you know the observations are noted Y
and Z's [clears throat] are noted with X
so P of Y would be the model evidence.
So you can see okay well for a given
unidimensional
set of observations you might imagine
that there's some this is in this case
this is a Gaussian or a normal
distribution over what the model
evidence would be
given your model okay That's the really
crucial thing. And we're going to see in
the next example, the example at the end
of 4.3, that the model evidence is
something that is always tied to a
particular model. So, there's no such
thing as the model evidence, kind of, as
the name would imply, you know, without
a model. Um the idea is that the model
evidence is is a score about
uh how plausible
your model thinks a given observation
is, okay? So, there's this subtle
distinction to be made between what
actually comes in from your sensory
apparatus, from the generative process,
and the thing that your model is uh
scoring as a plausible thing that could
come in.
Um there's I guess so we we we we spent
a long time with chapters sort of 1 to 2
talking about distinction between the
generative process and the generative
model. It's going to come up again here,
um those kind of theoretical issues
about what belongs to what. We can get
back into that again if necessary, but
hopefully we can take some of that uh
for granted now.
So, all this was looking at, and I
believe this is figure, let's have a
look, figure 4.5.
We're just looking at the relationship
between the model evidence and what's
known as the surprise, okay? And I think
the very last thing we ended up with was
kind of just saying or stating what the
surprise is.
And mathematically, it's very simple.
It's just the negative of the log of the
model evidence.
So, okay, that's fine. And that's this
is what you get when you plot this,
okay? Kind of the inversion of the
surprise. Sorry, the model evidence.
Now, what does this mean? So,
similarly with
you know, the the the surprise, again,
it you it's it's defined with respect to
a particular choice of model.
It's effectively the degree of
implausibility
of observing something given a model,
okay? So, the idea is that if I get
observations that are around about
zero-ish,
I'm going to be very unsurprised
colloquially
if I get those observations cuz my model
is going to predict that I would get
those observations. It It's You can
imagine our our choice of model is
predicting, "Okay, I'm going to get
observations close to zero." And things
far away from zero, you know, minus two
or two, I'm going to be very very
surprised if I see those if I do get
them in as observations.
So,
colloquially, this is at least the
relationship between model evidence and
surprise.
And the big thing is that surprise is
the thing that we're trying to bound
with our our inference procedures. We're
trying to make sure that um
we would like to calculate it, but
usually it's impossible to calculate.
And it's impossible to calculate usually
because the model uh the
the model evidence is impossible to
calculate. And there's a nice
relationship depicted over here between
the two quantities. Um
So, as you if you have very high uh
model evidence, you've got very low
surprise
because that corresponds to the case
where your model is very good at
uh
predicting the kinds of observations
that would come in, okay? If conversely
you have very very low surprise,
uh sorry, very low model evidence, that
means that you're very surprised by the
observations that are coming in. So,
you're not actually very able to to
calculate what's happening
or to anticipate what's happening,
rather. That's the crucial thing I think
that's that's useful for this concept is
I like to think of it in terms of
anticipation.
Um so, you know, I've I've got a model
and I'm trying to predict what's going
to come in from my sensory epithelium.
I can either be surprised or not, and I
would like to not be surprised.
So, there is a
that's taken up very beautifully in this
example here. This is example
0.3, is that right?
Do do.
Think of 4.6, rather.
And we're looking at example 4.2. So,
this is on page 85. This is a very very
nice demonstration about
uh what these things mean. What this
model evidence means, and what this
surprisal sort of means.
So, I mean, just well, one potentially
interesting anecdote,
let's contextualize this.
I was sitting at home the other day, and
a postman came to the door, and he
handed me a package, and the package had
all over it like in in red Well, sorry,
bright red letters, "Bladed article."
And I was thinking, "Oh my god, what's
in here?" You know, this is this is
crazy. And so, I was trying to predict,
thinking, "Well, this this isn't for me,
this package." But what could possibly
be in there, you know?
Very interesting.
And so, I thought, "All right." And I
signed for it, I took it in, I took to
the kitchen, and I saw outside there's
other people living in this in this
house, there were a bunch of lawn mowers
that were disassembled. And I was
thinking, "Oh, okay. It's plausible that
the thing inside the package is, you
know, maybe a a lawn mower blade or
something like that."
So, what I was able to do was I was able
to update my prior belief about what
might be in the package on the basis of
sensory evidence. Of course, I don't
know if I was right. I didn't open the
package in the end. I think it probably
was a lawn mower blade. But you might
imagine that that model, okay, that the
thing that is inside the
the package is a lawn mower blade,
has good evidence given the observation
that I made that there were lawn mowers
that were disassembled everywhere, you
know?
It may still be the case that I was
wrong, but that's um
I think that's an
It struck me as a potentially
contextualizing anecdote about what's
going on here.
Um
Anyway, I think I think we should get
into the details of of this example, cuz
it really is clarifies a lot of things
very nicely.
Um
So, what are we actually looking at?
So again, example 4.2 on page 85.
What we're looking at is, if we have uh
on on the left panel,
imagine that we have a scenario wherein
our prior belief about what we might
um
about what we think the world is like,
so the state of the world, okay, X,
is centered about the state of the world
being being negative one.
Okay?
That's one one prior we can have. And
again, we're within this example of food
size and light intensity.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> what you have then is you say, okay,
well, on the uh
Do do do do
>> [clears throat]
>> Is it on the right or on the left?
I want to get this right here.
Uh
Yes, so
the the posterior belief
Uh sorry, no, not the posterior, but the
the the evidence
that you that's the model evidence that
you get when you get an observation in
assuming that the prior belief is this
red one is over here on the right, and
that's this green or, you know, gray
green distribution.
This is the model evidence that my model
is predicting I would get,
observations I would receive if my prior
belief was this red one.
Uh so, you can see that that's centered
around zero, okay? Now, here's the
here's the crucial thing. Imagine that
we get an observation that is minus one.
This one here.
Uh well,
that means that our model evidence is
not very good because this model is not
very close to It's not predicting that I
would get very many minus ones. It's
predicting I would get a lot of zeros,
basically.
Uh and so, this is not a good model.
This is This is in comparison to other
models wherein you might imagine that we
would have higher
uh
model evidence, basically. I think I was
I think I was wrong, by the way. I think
this uh
uh
do do
Nope, I was right.
So, imagine instead
if you had a different prior,
uh
this one. Is that right?
P X up. Unfortunately, he's equivocating
on the notion of an update here. So,
there's an updated
We usually when we speak of an updated
prior, we talk about a posterior
distribution, but in this case, update
just means there's one kind of prior,
and then we're going to consider a
different kind of prior.
A little bit of a unfortunate
derivative, um,
for sure. So,
if instead I had a a model which more
adequately predicted was was uh,
better centered on on uh,
the true state of the world, and then I
got an observation in
that was again minus one. You can see
that in this case, the model evidence is
directly centered on that. So, this is a
model with good Well, it has very high
model evidence, basically.
Uh, and so, it's a better model. And
what we can do is we can use we can
directly use these values to score
between different models. Okay, so we
only have two models here.
I think he says on that page
that uh, you can't directly score them.
So, model one,
you know, the probability of an
observation point one or so, centered on
x equals zero. That's this this green
one.
Green one. Model two, the up the model
evidence gives you 1.33.
Centered on
uh,
x equals minus one.
So, comparing these two two models, we
can see that the evidence is higher in
the second model.
Uh, that means taking taking into
account new information, we have a
better model of the incoming sensory
data.
Uh, and that process that process of of
comparing models is called Bayesian
model comparison. It's very I mean,
there's a lot of work that goes on with
Bayesian model comparison, especially in
like things like experimental design.
Very very big area, but um,
this is very very
interesting now, because we have a way
of kind of scoring how well our models
fit to
uh, to data, given given their their
evidence.
Uh, and there's also figure 4.7. This is
another kind of visualization of the
same procedure.
I go here.
So, this is maybe a little bit nicer
actually to look at. Imagine you've got
a true distribution
or a true
model being blue.
That would result in observations that
are sampled that are around about zero.
And then imagine you've got your two
models. You've got a green model which
is kind of close to the true one. That's
going to give you samples of
observations that are very close to the
true distribution. But this red one
here, this is kind of off kilter. It's
not going to give you observations that
are centered about true mean.
Um
And so on the basis of those
model evidences, you can compare the two
models and say, "Okay, well, which one's
which one's better?"
Uh
very nice. Of course, it is a little bit
uh
we're sort of cheating a little bit
because we know that we can't directly
assess the model evidence usually, you
know, in the general case.
Uh if we could, we would have a a way of
scoring our models such that they could
become perfect. But we actually can't
directly calculate the model evidence.
That's the whole bugbear of this whole
chapter.
And that's going to motivate why this
That's again another motivational the
primary motivation, I think,
as to where
the uh the variational free energy comes
from.
So, again, we we we started to halfway
through 4.3. We introduced the D form of
variational free energy last time.
Uh so, that was that's in section 4.3.
I go to the equations.
I just want to show it again cuz it is
instructive. It's called the D form
because it emphasizes a divergence.
Uh we're going to see what kind of
divergence in particular.
There are lots of divergences floating
around.
That's that's for sure.
Uh 4.18,
here we go.
So, this is the expression for the
variational free energy expressed uh in
on page 84.
This is what's known as the D form.
Uh so, the idea is we have our
surprisal, okay? But, we also have this
divergence now between the approximate
posterior and the true posterior.
And this term here is called the
divergence, no qualifications necessary.
It's a little bit
unfortunate that that's its name because
the KL divergence is used all over the
place, and it's used not necessarily
with only these arguments here. But,
you're in this in this specific form of
the variational free energy, you'll see
this term referred to as the divergence.
That's usually what is meant by
divergence.
And again, the the naming, you know,
D-form
or G-form, these are just Sanjeev's
labels [clears throat] he's come up,
you know, exposed to to to label the
different kinds of VFE.
>> I can understand why they chose the term
divergence specifically for that case
because it's
the divergence of Q of X from the actual
posterior,
um which which this all about.
Um
so, I can understand why they
specifically chose that name for that um
>> Yeah, cuz I mean, you obviously want
your
approximate posterior to be as close to
the true posterior as possible. So, it
does
Yeah, it there is a there is a
non-arbitrary reason why it is called
the divergence. It's just it can be a
little bit confusing given that there
are lots of divergences floating around,
but for sure.
Although, of course, this expression, as
we saw, you know, last time, it's not
too helpful because we still can't
calculate the exact posterior.
So, this is this is an algebraic,
you know, a specialization about what
the VFE could be. It can be expressed in
this way. But, when we're actually
calculating it, we we can't use this
expression because
we would have to know the true posterior
to begin with. And that sort of
motivates the other forms. Obviously, we
saw the G form last time.
Uh that was the first uh form expressed
in terms of the generative model
only. Uh where is that? Do do do do do.
4.9. Yeah, 4.9A.
So, usually Yeah, there we go. You'll
usually sort of see
the VFE introduced in this way. So, we
have This is the KL divergence between
the approximate posterior and the
generative model. Okay. And obviously,
we know by the rules of probability, we
can factorize our generative model in
terms of the prior on states and our
likelihood of observations.
Uh and we can do some sort of yoga
around that to get different forms out.
And there's two other forms. So, we
we've covered the the G and the D form
today. And we saw we took a lot look at
coordinate descent variational free
energy minimization. So, that is this
figure here.
Just want to show it again. That's what
my animation shows, by the way, the
current one.
Uh
figure figure figure.
That is this one.
So, the idea is you start out on, you
know, obviously, we're assuming that our
probability distributions are Gaussian
or normal distributions, and you walk
around in the cardinal directions here
for the the mean and the variance until
you get to a local minimum, basically.
And that's that's the
the the scheme that we saw last time.
It's a very powerful scheme, uh but
there are issues with it
um
that we will see shortly, basically.
So, that covers Well, except for
uh
I want to get to Yeah, 4.21A
and B. This is really the key of this
section here. So,
4.21A and B.
Uh we may not have them in here.
Well, this this will do. 4.11 does
exactly the same thing.
This is kind of what we want to say in
this whole section is we want to say
that
the
the surprisal
and I again
we typically use this comes out of
physics. This is just more notation,
more history as the way these things
come from. We typically use Z, capital
Z, to denote the marginal evidence or
the
uh you know, P of Y basically.
Uh Z is just another notation you'll
see. So, that the minus log of Z is the
minus log of P of Y. That's our our
surprisal.
This is by means of Jensen's inequality,
which we'll see just now,
approximately equal to what you get when
you minimize the variational free
energy.
And we've seen that the variational free
energy in the G form takes in an
approximate posterior and the generative
model, okay?
So, you minimize your variational free
energy
by doing what?
By changing the approximate posterior,
okay? So, that's what this mean Q thing
means. It says, "Take the minimum of the
VFE."
That's
uh well, by changing Q in such a way
that you get the minimum VFE.
When you do that, you have something
that is approximately equal to the
evidence over here. And that is
excellent because that means we can
start approximating Bayes' rule and we
can start doing approximate inference.
That's kind of the whole linchpin of of
this section here.
So, we need to you know, this He spends
quite a while, you know, from 4.21A all
the way to
uh 4.23A
and then to 26, so page 87
and 88 explaining why this works. So,
what like why is this the relationship
between the surprisal? Why is why is
there a
relationship between the surprisal and
the VFE?
There is there are reasons for that and
let's let's try and maybe get a sense as
to why
this relationship doesn't obtain.
>> [clears throat]
>> Now, to do that, I'm going to go back to
the equations. First of all,
that's
I'm moving quick I'm aware of the fact
that I'm moving quite quickly and and
there's a lot of material. Is there
anyone who would like to ask anything at
this stage? Cuz we're going to go into
some more material after this.
So, do do put up your hand if you would
like to. 4.24 is what I want.
Bottom of the email. Cool. Actually, no.
2.3 and 4.23a.
And
do we have it?
We may not.
I'll have to go and add that later. So,
well, the um
It would be nice to show it. 4.23a.
Oh, we really don't. Oh, it's this one
here. 4.2.
Was that a question I hear?
>> Oh.
>> Andrew.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, thanks. Uh
also
those equations should be in there. I
don't know if it's doing some kind of
sorting because of the
because of the
being in there. Um
It's strange. Um
but yeah, the um
I mean, it this is just slightly
not quite a question, although it's open
to conversation, of course, but like I
think part of the usefulness of the the
D form, even though it's kind of
understood like we're not exactly
um Oh, yeah, there you go. Um but yeah,
for for the D form including the the
unfortunately named or not like
divergence term, um I think that it's
it's very illustrative to simply make
the point that if we could minimize that
divergence to virtually zero, then you
would see that the, you know, suddenly F
on the left equals uh the surprisal. So,
I think this this form is it's not so
much to say, "Oh, we're going to be
immediately directly using it." Rather,
it's just like kind of making the point
that you could rearrange things in order
to see this like potential equality
between variational free energy and
surprisal where we see that the only
thing that's that's preventing us from
being able to say that they're
equivalent is that we might have this
kind of divergence
um our variational posterior with some
kind of true posterior. So, um yeah, I
think for exposition it's an interesting
way of looking at it and then it we're
just bearing in mind that we don't
necessarily
directly use this if we were
programming something um
or otherwise. And um yeah, it I mean, I
I don't want to rehash much of what
you've said. You've you've covered it
really well.
Um
but I think um yeah, for like
like figure point 4.6 that we were
looking at where we see um these sort of
like updates
um
what's what's being ignored is something
like updating like there's no learning
in here. That's Well, there's sort of is
in that we're we're updating our prior,
but it's not showing anything this isn't
revealing anything within the context of
this single figure about the likelihood.
So, that's the only thing that's sort of
missing from allowing us to sort of see
the full update, right? Because we would
have with Bayes' theorem like that's
that's kind of the missing piece. We we
we see our P of X, we see our P of Y, so
we're just missing the the likelihood
that allows us to link them. Um and then
>> That's implicit. It's implicit, yeah.
Yeah.
>> Right. Uh exactly. And so, I with this I
I only wanted to touch on it again in
that we can kind of see how
with the more um you know, the the kind
of smaller bell-shaped
distributions, which are the pre-update
distributions for P of X and P of Y. We
notice that whenever we receive this
data point
and we use it for our updates, suddenly
our
kind of updated P of X becomes much
sharper and looks much more kind of
spike-like. It's more concentrated
around roughly 1.5
and then similarly for P of Y, it
becomes for P of Y becomes much more
concentrated around a -1.
So, if we thought of that in terms of
like the the variance, just as we've
been talking about like having a a
variance or you could do the reciprocal
and have like a precision term,
that being the the the inverse of the
variance,
the the precision has increased whenever
it reaches this more spike-like shape.
So, that's something that's also maybe
missing from this figure, but it's nice
to think about like you know, here are
the things that aren't shown in the
figure that that kind of help us
contextualize these things and then you
know, it it almost looks cumbersome here
because now we're like looking at these
two different metrics, but we have a
our our
the the sort of mode of the P of Y,
which is you know, it gets updated to
1.33. That is a good thing.
The surprisal reduces,
which is also a good thing.
Um,
simply they're separated by the fact
that one of them is a negative log
transform of the other.
So, they're you know, there's kind of
this ratio between them and
yeah, so it's it's just like you know,
tracking all these little things that
are here, but ideally we would say this
is a good update and then as Fraser
mentioned earlier with Bayesian model
comparison,
again, we don't necessarily know the
true model unless we're doing a highly,
you know, kind of um,
sort of scripted simulation where we
say, "Okay, well,
you know, if we're the ones who define
the environment and we know exactly how
it works, then we would be able to do
something like see how good this model
is with respect directly to the
environment." But, in a real-world
circumstance where we don't know the
true environment, one of the best things
we could possibly do is say, "Well, how
well is my model predicting these
observations that it's receiving?"
Because at least the model can kind of
be good relative unto itself. It might
not be perfectly approximating um the
the the environment, but it can get
closer to being able to predict the
observations it receives well, which
means it is doing something like
approximating the environment well, even
if it's not structured similarly to the
environment or or maybe there's
something in our model that's, you know,
it's missing a component or a piece that
would uh be necessary for uh allowing it
to equate to the environment. Um so,
this is why we do this kind of Bayesian
model comparison. We can kind of see how
good models are relative unto
themselves. Um and so, if our model
becomes better at being able to predict
the observations it receives, which we
see on the right uh subplot there with
the p of y, then we could say, "Well,
you know, unto itself, it's becoming
much better at being able to to predict
the environment." Um
anyway, yeah, that's uh my my
sub-lecture within a lecture. So, all
right.
>> Thank you, Andrew. And and there's
there's there's debates that we can get
into, especially later on, about, you
know, okay, well, is the is the model
evidence better because your model is
literally more like the environment, the
generative process,
or does it not have to be literally more
like it? You know, there's there's very
interesting questions about that. Uh
we're not going to look at that just
now, but we want to get a sense of
again, what this model evidence even is
and and how we how we bound it with
VAEs. So, I want to turn to to to
equation 4.23,
uh where we'll we'll then have a look at
Jensen's inequality, and then we'll sort
of round out things with the rest of the
the other two um decompositions of the
VFE, and then we can take some
questions. Well, I'm I'm happy to take
questions at any point if there are if
there are questions, so don't hesitate
to interrupt me.
Uh so, I had I had it up before here.
It's all the way down here.
Unfortunately, Coda does kind of uh play
around with how it orders things, which
is very entertaining.
2 3. Okay.
So, okay. What are we doing? But, we're
trying to get a sense of why the VFE is
related to surprisal, all right? Here's
how I'm going to do it. So, we know how
to get Well, we know mathematically how
to express the surprisal. It's the
negative log of the model evidence, all
right? Well, how do we get the model
evidence? Well, we take our generative
model, P of X and Y, whatever it is,
and we marginalize across all the
possible hidden states.
Now, in a continuous model like the one
we have here, this is an integral over
our model with respect to hidden states
X. That gives us
P of Y. Perfect.
So, then we can just take the negative
log of P of Y, and we've got our model
evidence, so.
Again, one thing useful bookkeeping to
keep in mind is the negative log of the
model evidence. This is often just
denoted as capital Z.
So, you'll see that coming up.
So, this I mean, it's expressed on the
page as just another line in the
equation, but on page 88, we immediately
go from to 4.23a to 4.23b,
where this is exactly the same thing,
except now what we've done is we've
taken the inside of the integral,
and we've multiplied by one.
Uh
so, why have we done that? Well, what
we've done is we've multiplied by our
approximate posterior
divided by our approximate posterior.
So, anything divided by itself is one,
so we actually haven't changed this
equation at all. Okay? All we've done is
we've introduced we've snuck in through
the back door uh through the back door
our approximate posterior into this
whole setup here, but we haven't would
changed anything just yet.
Okay.
The crucial thing to
to see here
is that what we have
this this integral of Q of X times you
know P of X divided by Q of X blah blah
blah
this whole thing can actually be read as
an expectation.
Okay?
So and again
Daniel mentioned this in his session.
There's sort of two senses in which we
use the word or term expectation. It can
either mean the average value of a
probability distribution.
That's one sense. Or it can mean what
we're predicting we're going to observe
basically.
They can be exactly the same thing.
They're not always exactly the same
thing.
In the
I I want you to understand
when I use the word expectation for the
next few minutes that we're referring to
just the average of a probability
distribution. Okay?
So what is the probability distribution
in question?
It's actually this whole generative
model divided by the approximate
posterior
weighted by
the approximate posterior. This whole
thing
is an expectation mathematically
speaking.
Uh we have some
and and the way that you typically see
this
uh
is notated like this. You'll have this
kind of fancy script E basically which I
don't see Oh here we go. Perfect.
Uh
da da da
So you know expectation of X
for a continuous random variable is an
integral of
X times f of X.
That's an expectation. So that that's
the value the average value
of the function we're concerned with.
So what function are we concerned with
here? We are concerned with I want to go
back here.
Uh P the generative model divided by the
approximate posterior
weighted by the approximate posterior.
That is the expectation that we're
talking about. Now here's the here's the
thing.
We can actually kind of do a little bit
of a trick here and the trick is 4.24.
And this is going to simplify things
enormously. That's all the way back up
here, I think.
4.24
Yes, perfect.
Okay, so we're going to try and hold in
our head what F was.
But the key idea, and we're going to see
why this is the case, is that the
expectation of
a concave function, so one that kind of
slopes, you know, downwards in some
respect,
evaluated at some
some point,
is always greater than or equal to
the concave function evaluated at the
expectation of that point. Oh my dear,
what's going on here?
So,
what this actually means, let's let's
come back to 4.24,
in the guise of 4.25 and then I I swear
that will be the last equation we look
at before we look at the animation.
So, 25
I think it's probably all the way down
here, isn't it?
23, here we go. There it perfect.
All right, so we we had this is our
expectation, well,
we're now substituting into what I just
showed you, 4.24,
the particular F in question.
Um and the particular F in question is
well, this over here.
So, I general model divided by the
approximate posterior, weighted by the
approximate posterior. That's our F,
basically.
Jensen's inequality tells us that if we
we're going to pass that through a
concave function,
then there's a certain relationship that
obtains between the expectation of one
thing and the function evaluated at the
expectation.
All right, last bit. What is that
function we're putting it through?
Log. We're putting it through the
logarithm. Okay? So, the idea is that
the negative logarithm of an expectation
I'm going to read it from right to left
is less than or equal to
the expectation
of the logarithm of that function.
All right. That's I think what I'll do
is I'll I'll put some animation together
that make this a little bit more clear
in terms of the steps that I've gone
through to go from 2.3a to 2.3b uh 4.24
and then all the way to the 4.26.
But, this is the crucial step here. This
is the thing that allows us to
um
bound the model evidence. And it's it's
shown directly. So, now now we take this
equation here and we can just kind of
re-express it as as 4.25b.
So, I'm saying now the expectation
of the log of something
under our approximate posterior is
greater than or equal to the negative
log
of the expectation of a something. Okay?
That's the crucial thing. This is this
is
>> Um yeah. Yeah, Fraser, um it's actually
really straightforward if one just
plainly thinks of a function as
literally
q of x over p of x, y. That's the
function.
And on the left side
on the left side is the expectation
um of the function the log of the
function. And on the right side that
minus just flips the numerator and
denominator. So, first one could write
it as
the same as on the left side being qx
over pxy.
And then in the next step uh bring out a
minus that just flips the numerator and
denominator.
>> Yeah, that's just by the rule the rule
of logarithms for sure. Yeah. But,
there's a there's a beautiful
visualization of of why this is the
case, which
um maybe I'll try and I'll now.
So, we go back to the actual notes on
the page.
So, this is Jensen's inequality I'll
play and
So, the idea is okay, our F is in this
case as Kobus just said, it's the
logarithm of X. That's what our function
is. That's what the logarithm of X looks
like. In this case, it's a concave
function. It only ever monotonically
increases, okay? So, X is our hidden
states, log of X on on the Y axis.
The idea is we can take
two points. Let's take X1 and X2.
Uh and we can take their average.
Well, first of all, we can see okay,
well, what's the logarithm of X1? It's
over here on the left. What's the
logarithm of X2? It's over here on the
left again.
Uh but we can also take the average or
the expectation of these two points over
here. That's E of X. That's kind of in
the middle, as you can see.
And the crucial relationship is that
the expectation of or the logarithm of
the expectation of X. So, here's the
expectation of X. Go up, take the
logarithm. There's the logarithm of the
expectation.
That is always greater than or equal to
the expectation of the logarithm of X.
That's the crucial thing.
So, there we go. Log of expectation
greater than equal to the expectation of
the log.
Um and all those minus signs do that we
were looking at is just flip around
inside, you know, the function that we
were looking at what's divided by what.
So, I wouldn't get too hung up on that
for now. But hopefully, this is
something of a a way to get a sense
about where Jensen's inequality comes
from and you know, how how it sort of
works in this way.
Once we have that, we can go back
and we can say, well,
uh excellent.
Therefore, 4.26 is what we end up with.
So, I think it's all the way back up
here.
Ooh, there it is, yeah. Perfect.
Finally, we end up with this. The
variational free energy is is greater
than or equal to the minus log of P of X
always greater than or equal to the log
evidence.
And that is just because
uh the the expression that we saw
before, so the left-hand side
uh of 4.25b is the variational free
energy.
Uh 4.25b, I just want to linger on that.
Uh
yes.
Now, this thing on the left-hand side,
that's literally the variational free
energy in the G form, okay? And it's
always greater than or equal to the uh
log evidence, basically.
This is excellent. This is uh the thing
that allows us to to approximate
Bayesian evidence. Uh sorry, uh Bayesian
inference. So, in the in in exact
Bayesian inference, um the variational
free energy becomes equal to the
surprise. And then we don't actually
have to do variational inference. We can
just do uh Bayesian inference, but
usually we can't because the problems
we're looking at are too difficult.
That's the key central move of this this
whole chapter is explaining where the
VFE comes from in terms of surprise.
Now, from 4.44 onwards, you know,
intuition for other forms of the
variational free energy,
what we do is we just kind of walk
through different ways you can do the
kind of mathematical yoga for expressing
um
the the VFE. So, there's there's four
canonical forms that he gives you in
this chapter. 4.27 is the next one.
And there's a nice figure that goes
along with this, too.
Uh
So, this is this uh the D Well, we've
seen the D That's the D form where
you've got your divergence
between the approximate posterior and
the true posterior.
The C form is very interesting,
especially for those who have a machine
learning background. So, this is 4.28.
Now, this one here.
Uh again, I I'll try to make an
animation as to, you know, where this
other uh derivation comes from. I think
Kobus, you've already done some nice
hand-drawn derivations as well. They'll
they'll be very helpful uh to go
through. But you can express the the VFE
in terms of two other terms that if seen
before, to commonly called complexity
and then the accuracy, complexity minus
accuracy.
Um and so this is, you know, the in you
know, the complexity is kind of
motivated by the idea that there's a
divergence between the approximate
posterior um and the prior belief that
you have.
And so you you might imagine, okay, if
you have to change your mind a lot
uh when you do your inference, that's
like a really complex thing, basically.
So you've got some prior belief, you you
do some inference and your your your
belief changes. If it changes a very
large amount,
there was a there was a complex process
that went on. That's kind of
colloquially why it's referred to as
complexity.
Um and then accuracy, this is kind of
the uh
what you know, the score about how well
your your
um
recovering your ability to predict given
[snorts] given the observations.
So again, that is just another form
that's out there and, you know, Sanjeev
calls it the C form for complexity,
uh highlighting that there. There you
can you can convert all of these forms
into each other. There's very standard
ways to do that. Um it's not too tricky.
Again, that is this is this is most
um familiar and and and useful and
applicable to people from I I would say
a machine learning background and they
deal with complexity and accuracy and
the trade-off between them. Usually
usually you can't do both at the same
time. They're sort of, you know, they're
competing with one another. This is a
very familiar situation for machine
learning people to be in.
The last form and then maybe we can get
to some some questions to the E form. So
that's 4.29 A and B.
Which I think I have.
Here we go. Oh, there we are.
So E for
entropy and energy, basically. So
you can express again, you know, two
different terms, the negative entropy
and the negative energy. So the entropy
of a probability distribution or a
you know, continuous probability
distribution is the expectation
of the log of that distribution
effectively under itself. So,
this is a a measure of how spread out
the distribution is.
Uh and then, you know, the the energy is
almost the same thing algebraically
speaking, except we're taking the log of
the generative model here.
Again, this is another common
um
variant. And then, you can
you know,
a different way to express it, exactly
the same thing mathematically, just
different notation in terms of the
closed form expectations. So,
those are the four canonical
representations of the VAE. Uh they show
up again and again and again, and
they're used all over the place in other
other kinds of VAE that are built from
them
um take these things as their starting
points effectively. So,
this is the
uh
you know, they're the big four kind of
variants that you'll you'll see
throughout the literature.
Any other questions? Otherwise, we're
going to go into free form variational
inference, and then fixed form VAE, and
that actually rounds out the entire
chapter.
Um and then, we do another kind of
coordinate ascent uh
uh scheme. I'll just point out in in
section 4.7, there is this diagram,
uh which is helpful, but it's it's
actually incorrect. We pointed it out
the first time.
Uh
I'm
not quite sure where it is.
So, it's you know, he lists the G form,
the D form, the C form, the E form. I
think it's here, actually.
Uh
this one.
The forms of free energy. Uh this is
actually subtly incorrect.
Um first of all, as as Koba's pointing
out, the surprise we have should uh go,
you know, cover the minus sign as well.
Um if you're wondering what this symbol
is here, this is something called it's
it's the symbol theta, the Greek letter
theta, but it's
a different font, if you will. It's
called var theta.
Um this is our hidden state, okay? So,
he's chosen to change the notation.
Anyway, you see this by theta, that
should be a hidden state, okay?
Although, of course, in the D form, we
should have our divergence, that's
correct, but the surprisal is the minus
log of the probability of observations
Y. So, this is a typo here, should be it
should be Y.
Other than that, it's all correct.
We'll we'll we'll add that to the errata
if we haven't already. That's the only
thing to note.
Okay. Any questions? Any any hands up or
anything?
I see that there are some things in the
chat.
No, okay.
>> Just check briefly.
Yeah, the um
I shared just a couple links to
different things, but the the whole
point is um
you know, that
for anyone who's wondering like, okay,
are we not just doing some kind of
tricks with logs? How does this actually
relate to neuroscience or any of the the
other like actual, you know, scientific
fields to which these things relate? And
it's just to make the point that there's
actually these kind of long-running
traditions of thinking like, how does
the brain actually carry out
computations? And so, all the way down
to like, just as we have a phrase like
the the Bayesian brain hypothesis,
there's also been the phrase of a
logarithmic brain, uh which it which is
very interesting for anyone who sort of
wants to go deeper into to that line of
thinking, all the way down to like, the
way that neurons
um
kind of spike and and how frequently
they they spike and different
populations spike relative to one
another. If you actually start plotting
that, it starts to look like a
logarithmic distribution. And similarly,
with um, you know, how sensory
information is being processed, this
goes back even further, the idea that
there's some kind of log transform. And
it's just to make the point that just
because our standard view of mathematics
and how we tend to think about things,
Bayes' theorem, and so on, where we're
not necessarily using logs right away,
that might seem more intuitive to us. We
grow up thinking about it like that, but
there's no reason to assume that the
brain carries out non-logarithmic
operations, right? It's like from the
flip side, it's like that's what we sort
of have science has to sort of discover
things over time, right? So,
um yeah, it's it's very interesting.
It's just to kind of seal the seal the
deal a little bit on like why are we
doing these things with logs? It's
actually much more empirically plausible
than than what it might seem rather than
it just being a sort of trick we do
solely within the realm of, you know,
variational free energy minimization or
something.
>> That's a good point. There there is an
enormous amount of empirical work on on
yeah, the use of these exact
mathematical formulations for doing
actual modeling, for sure. Yeah, they
don't and especially you see a lot of
like Boltzmann
models and things like that which use,
you know, logs and and such like. So, it
isn't it isn't just kind of a weird that
hawk thing,
for sure. Verena, you've got your your
hand up.
>> Yeah, I'm just trying to to build an
intuition here. So,
the expectation basically is a
compression of all of my uncertain
uncertainties
into a single usable guess like
like your example today that it is a
razor blade in the package or
and you're giving
you're spelling out weights or you you
you imagine possibilities as weights. Am
I am I
Yeah.
>> Yeah, yes. Let's take Let's take the E
form as as a way to answer that
question.
It's good just cuz it kind of shows you
where the expectations are. Yeah, the
expectation of something, in this case
it's probability distribution,
is in some sense the average of that
thing, you know.
So, the idea is like let's let's let's
just take the entropy
term, okay? So, we've got the
expectation of the log of Q, the log of
my approximate posterior. This is a
belief about what I think the world is
like.
Uh,
under, you know, values from my
approximate posterior. So, this is like,
okay, well, what is the average value of
this thing
weighted by, multiplied by values taken
from Q of X. It's kind of, yeah, it's a
it's a it's effectively an average, or a
weighted average.
I mean, that's literally what it is in
the discrete case.
Um,
uh,
I don't know how helpful this will be to
see exactly, but um,
you're you are right in that your
your intuition as to what like what an
expectation is
is a kind of average of that thing.
I don't know if I I've helped too much
other than just kind of
agree. Do you do you have any anything
you'd rather highlight there, um,
Andrew, or um,
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Does that get it?
>> I I think it's I mean, in a sense, it is
definitely a compression. You know, if
we're looking at something like, um,
you know, our distribution P of X, and
then we we sort of take some kind of
average or expectation over that, then
we're doing something like saying like,
well, on average, the prior, you know,
sort of should be this. Or if we're
looking at at P of Y, then we're saying
like, on average, the the generated
data, the observation is something like
like this, um, rather than saying it's a
whole range. Uh, we're just kind of like
taking that distribution or that range,
and then just kind of finding what is
the sort of average expected value of
that. So, it is very much a kind of
compression. Um, that said,
it just in the context of what's being
shown here, we're not saying that this
is the the kind of expectation of
uncertainty.
Um, it with respect to like P of X and P
of Y, we're actually saying not the
opposite. So, I don't I don't want to
ruin the the intuition there, but it
we're just kind of compressing like what
we do actually expect, right? It's just
sort of the the
not quite the reverse of uncertainty,
but like we feel more certain that if we
did have to say, you know, let's say for
for the P of Y, right? The
the models sort of distribution
of how it sees the observations that are
coming in. We know that Y is for the
observations. So, whenever we sort of
compress that by by by saying like
what's the expectation of P of Y, what
we're saying is on average the model
expects this particular value of Y. Out
of this this whole distribution of
potential Y values that we could
receive, of potential observations, on
average we would receive the expectation
of that P of Y distribution.
It becomes quite handy in different
kinds of operations or, you know,
another way of thinking about it in
terms of intuition is like, you know,
oh, on the day-to-day I expect to see
such and such. Out of these out of this
whole distribution of different things
that kind of could happen, um,
you know, the
if I had to narrow it down and say
what's the if I could boil it down,
compress it down to what's one thing
that could happen like most often would
happen, it would be that expectation.
>> I see. So, it's basically it's a
hypothesis, a usable one,
that maybe is productive.
>> Yeah.
I think it aligns with the a very good
idea of thinking about it something like
this is sort of a hypothesis. It's like,
well, we have a whole distribution. So,
if I wanted to report to you what I
think is going to happen,
I could I could give you this broad
distribution of things that could happen
where I I accounting for uncertainty
or I can take an expectation, kind of
average over all of that, and be able to
tell you a single value like, well, most
often I would expect that Y is going to
be 1.5. It could be 1.4, it could be,
you know, two and so on, all these other
values that may you know, have a
non-zero probability in the distribution
as well.
Um, but but if but if I had to give you
a best guess based on the distribution I
have, it would be the expectation of
that distribution.
>> I see. Thank you.
>> Yeah, I would say it's literally a
weighted average. Each possible value in
the distribution is simply weighed by
its probability.
As simple as that.
>> Yep.
>> And there's yeah, well
>> Yeah, and the the reason
>> [clears throat]
>> we do it, I
I uh assume,
uh is that we try to cut out noise and
look for the invariant properties.
>> It That is one of It's one of the
reasons we could. Um,
the
that is that is a plausible reason why
you might
uh do so, but um it's not the only
reason, uh for sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's it's like we'll we'll see
this come up in different sort of places
and we we saw way back in in like
looking at linear models in in chapter
two before we started getting into this
kind of more probabilistic Bayesian
setting.
Um,
we saw that like you could have a
distribution, but if you just kind of
take the expectation and just ignore all
the uncertainty, ignore all the stuff
about, oh, this is actually based on a
whole distribution where Y could be a
variety of values, you know, but certain
ones seem to be more probable. Uh we we
could compress everything from the
start. Simply say, "Oh, we're only
focused on the expectation." If we only
focus on the expectation, then we ignore
the fact that we're actually thinking
about a whole potential distributions of
things that could happen. So, that
allows for a very quick, easier
computation of of many things cuz now
you're just dealing with one value
instead of dealing with a whole
distribution that has a mean parameter
and a variance parameter and all the
rest. So, we take that expectation is
very I I like that you introduced the
word compression because it's just kind
of letting It's kind of just keeping the
mean of your distribution and ignoring
variance. You're ignoring that it could
vary. That also means that there could
be some kind of uncertainty involved in
in making predictions using it. You're
just saying, "Oh, I'll just boil
everything down to what's the
most probable value. What's the What's
the expected value here of of what would
happen?" But But it is removing any kind
of information. If you only stick with
that, it's removing any information
about having a variance, having a
probabilistic distribution around this,
having a, you know, precision term. It's
It's much more difficult to evaluate how
good your your your predictions are
going to be because if you knew that
your precision was very high, you'd be
able to say more confidently that the
value will be such and such. If
precision was low, you could tell
someone, "Oh, I expect this, but I don't
feel confident about it." Like you lose
all of those things about about
confidence and all the rest. And that
sort of can lead to reduced accuracy,
right? So, for those interested in
machine learning or or just how does a
model learn and and and improve um by
losing that information about
uncertainty and so on, then then, you
know, those those are all things that
would be quite useful for making better
predictions. Um
yeah. And And I'll say since we're just
about out of time like uh you know, I'll
leave it to you Fraser how you want to
finish the rest of the session. I have
to leave unfortunately. But um we will
see for those who are still kind of
struggling a bit with chapter four cuz I
would say this is probably of course the
most dense
uh kind of intricate chapter that we've
seen so far. Um chapter five and the the
the chapters to come will will be
looking at more of a direct application
of these things.
Um it will probably lead to this sort of
retroactive
epiphany moments of like oh now I
understand chapter four better because I
got to see how it was applied in chapter
five and it helps me to even better
understand why we care about all these
things in chapter four. So I just want
to for anyone who's you know maybe
trying to keep up uh based on what I've
read I think it might be similar for
Daniel and and Fraser where we're all
reading ahead a bit. Um I think that if
probably some some gaps might be
addressed as we continue to read and
then of course for anyone who came to
this textbook who didn't just want to
focus on a thorough derivation of
variational free energy and and that's
it. Um yeah it'll show why all these
things in chapter four matter once we
start start seeing them be uh applied.
>> Yeah, totally. And this is this is
definitely the most this is like the
heart of the mathematical formalism for
active inference. So it's definitely
probably the hardest chapter.
Um
definitely the first part of the book
for sure. So well thank you Andrew. Um
well it's been good to have you so we'll
we'll see you next week. One thing I
would like to just say two two quick
things. We didn't do the last two
sections. Uh we didn't have really time
for them. So that's 4.5 free form mean
field variational inference.
The just really quickly the the thing I
want to say about what that even is is
if we go here. I don't know. I don't
think I have the equations just now.
Uh 4.37 the idea is that you can make an
assumption
about the nature of your variational
posterior.
So, you might have a belief over some
variable, in this case hidden state of
the world. If that's, you know,
position, velocity, color, blah blah
blah,
you can pretend that, okay, well, I
think this belief is equal to the belief
over the first component of my vector
times the belief over the second
component of my vector times the belief
over the third, blah blah blah blah
blah. And the idea is you kind of
break up or factorize your approximate
posterior belief. This is a very, very
common strategy that's used in the
literature.
It introduces approximation
error and things like that, but it is a
very
ubiquitous
Yeah, you know, way of of simplifying
the the problem. We can perhaps do some
revision on that next time. The other
thing is the last section is 4.6 fixed
form mean field variational inference.
So, this is called mean field. I won't
get into why that's that is. And the
idea with fixed form
in variational inference is that you
just say, well, I'm going to assume that
my posterior has a certain form, you
know? I'm going to assume it's Gaussian.
That's that's the assumption that we're
going to take throughout this book and
indeed that most people take. So, 4.46
is where that is.
Um very, very common
assumption. And then you just do the
usual story about uh um
mean field variational inference there
as well. So, we haven't had time to
cover that. Um and that brings us to the
end of the chapter to 4.7 summary and
conclusions. So, next week we're going
to do chapter five. That's predictive
coding. And we're going to get more into
um
it's going to be a bit of a breather, as
Andrew said. We're going to be able to
sort of reflect back and have a bit of
a, you know, digest of chapters one
through four.
And we're going to talk a bit about how
this might how this story might
plausibly apply to the brain, how the
brain might be able to do this,
basically.
That's that's kind of where we're going.
So, I'll stop the recording here.
Uh and then anyone who wants to stick
around for questions can do so. So,
uh
thank you. Until next time.